okay let's let's quickly study how to
compute surface levels because we are
going to need that if you remember the
diagrams
we always have the surface normal for a
diffuse specular and the ambient shading
and just a quick remark in the previous
lecture we have talked about diffuse and
specular shading and also ambient but
these are perhaps the most important
ones for the simplified PRDS the idea
Falls and you can see them everywhere so
when you are in public transport you can
think about what object could be what
exactly some objects are like a mixture
of these brdf models it is possible that
I have a diffuse object with a glassy or
specular coating on top of it and you
can move your head around like I told
you before and and see how the new
crafty object changes so a lot of you to
to marvel at and you will be able to
also understand that for instance if you
watch someone performing stand-up comedy
there are usually a lot of guys saying
humorous things and they almost always
wit wear makeup and the makeup artist
tells them that yes you need to wear
makeup and the artist says that no one
manly guy I don't want to wear makeup
and they say well I don't care you have
to because otherwise you are sparkly and
this means that they start sweating and
if they start sweating that the skin is
going to get a bit oily and then it is
specular it's more specular so it means
that if I turn my hat around if you look
a bit different so there's going to be
specular highlights and if you use
makeup then the specular highlights
disappear and the whole face is going to
be almost perfectly diffuse tougher it
doesn't distract your audience so light
transport is everywhere so if you ever
wear makeup then think about this
specular and diffuse into reflections
okay all right I guess so
surface normals I have an implicit
half of X Y to zero I would like to know
the notice of this surface how to
construct a normal where the normal is
given by the gradient of the function
and just a quick just a quick reminder
the gradient of the function this is a
3d function of XYZ and the gradient when
every coordinate gives you the
derivative of the function with respect
to a given coordinate let's see an
example imagine an elliptic parent you
don't have to imagine that because
there's going to be an image so this is
x squared over a squared and so on I'm
not gonna read formulae and this is how
it looks like and if I would like to put
together something like this then I have
to know that a and B are the curvatures
of this thing in different different
dimensions and therefore these values
are scalar values well let's compute the
surface normal of this elliptic
paraboloid but this would includes
differentiating the whole equation for
the first coordinate with respect to X
so let's differentiate this with respect
to X well x squared is going to be 2 X
and E squared is going to remain there
because it's a scalar multiplier why
does it depend on X it doesn't depend on
X therefore it falls on Z it doesn't
depend on X therefore the first
coordinate will be 2 x over a squared
what about the second term the second
term is the function differentiating
with respect to Y okay plus X depend on
Y no this term is going to be 0 what
about this Y squared is going to be 2y
over B squared Z doesn't depend on Y
therefore this is going to be the second
term what about the third term I in
front ate this function with respect to
Z Z doesn't depend on X someone let me
know I mean correct it doesn't depend on
it does it depend on Y it doesn't well
what's going to be the derivative of
this expression it's going to be minus a
bit light louder
it's going to be minus one okay let's
see okay we got this so we can construct
the surface level of an elliptic
paraboloid excellent so when we do this
intersection routine in waitressing I
have a way and I would like to intersect
this against every single object that is
in the room the question is what is the
first object that the Ray hits which
intersection am i interested in so there
may be many so if I loop the summer and
they intersect many different objects
but if these are not going to send or
finsih things are not transparent then I
am only going to see the first
intersection and that's it and the first
should be the closest so this should be
easy because we are using parametric
equations they depend on T and T is the
distance so basically what we get as an
output this is going to be a list of T
values that are interesting I'm
intersecting these objects a list of T's
two five ten minus two things like that
what the question is which one do I
choose out of this list of T's someone
help me out most positive C the smallest
positivity e so the negative ones are
not interested in like I told you long
politics politics free zone and I'm
going to be interested in the smallest
positive T this is a more or less true
negative T's we are not interested in we
have discussed this and the question is
can we take T equals zero and I'm not
telling this because I would be an
annoying mathematician and only half
mathematician and line along the kinder
ones if I'm not asking this because I
will be an annoying good magician I'm
asking this because this is going to
happen if you write a ray tracer so lots
of people are you know something is not
working when I have no idea what went
wrong it is
possible that T equals zero and we need
to handle this case so just a second
raise your hand if you if you know what
T equals zero means in an intersection
okay excellent I will have some of my
own pathway so do you mind okay have I
asked it before yeah just a minute ago
they're going to be out of order they
raise our hands okay yesterday my name
is Luke Garrett okay so what's happening
when T equals zero whose experiment so
we will shoot yes exactly so if we have
some amount of bounces if I get T equals
zero this means that I am exactly on the
surface of the object that I am bouncing
off of so if I intersect against the
sphere and I bounce the right back the
next after the next intersection routine
I am almost guaranteed to see machine
precision matters but mathematically I
am guaranteed to see T equals zero
because it's self intersection the rain
comes to this direction bounces back
from the table but it is on the top of
the table there's going to be like a
trivial intersection which is from the
starting point of the rim so we are not
interested in this so we are going to
take as a conclusion the smallest
non-negative and non zero T so in code
we usually put there an Epsilon like a
very small number and we say that if
it's the varies this number then I will
take the intersection because it's not
self intersection anymore okay after we
adjusted this a small beauty break this
is an image rendered with Lux render our
glorious renderer we are going to use
this later during the course and some
more motivation will be able to compute
images like that isn't this beautiful
the previous image the background was
rendered
josepho - that's just cheating well if
you are in the mood to model an
extremely high holy cow amazing
procedure greater than any person yeah
people do that too and yeah but it gives
you a really realistic light level to
see you can you can use this thing in a
later assignment to create beautiful
images parallel there's the course
gallery make sure to take a look because
for previous years people have created
some amazing amazing scenes raise your
hand if you have seen this gallery okay
from the people who are for people who
haven't seen raise your hand if you're
going to take a look at this after the
course okay excellent I didn't I didn't
see your hand what's up you have you
have not looped but you have - okay
because they're seriously some amazing
things and I wouldn't say some people
should have gone artists instead because
this would say something about their
knowledge and it's not the case at all
because these teams are really smart
guys but they have some amazing artistic
skills and I'm sure that there are some
artists inside some of you as well